okay hi everyone let's get
okay so so for today's lecture what
we're gonna do is look at the topic of
having tree recursive neural networks I
mean this is actually a topic which I
feel especially fond of and attached to
because actually when we started doing
deep learning friend or P at Stanford in
2010 really for the sort of period from
2010 to 2015 the dominant set of ideas
that we were working on was this topic
of how you could build a recursive tree
structure into neural networks so in a
way it's kind of funny that I'm only
getting to it now I mean there are sort
of reasons for that that I think there
are a bunch of interesting ideas here
which relate closely to linguistic
structure and so it's good stuff to have
seen but in practice these ideas have
proven kind of hard to scale and not
necessarily to work better in practice
than the kind of things that we've spent
more time on meaning things like looking
at LST M's and looking at transformers
and things like that and so that's kind
of why we sort of shunted them towards
the end of the curriculum but I want to
sort of say something about the
motivations and the way you can build
tree structures and neural networks and
look at some of the possibilities we
explored in during this class another
fact about this class is actually this
is the last class I'm going to give so
two more classes in the next week don't
forget about next week's cs2 24 in
classes but on Tuesday we've gone in the
final invited speaker make Mitchell
who's a great speaker and has tons of
interesting stuff to say about fairness
and ethics in NOP nai and then for the
final lectures one another my PhD
students Kevin Clark is going to give
that and talk about some of the recent
what's been happening in deep learning
in 2018-19 or some of the sort of recent
developments in NLP and deep learning so
as
I'll say my farewells at the end of this
one so hopefully everyone has submitted
their a milestone for their final
project if you haven't you should really
be getting your milestone in you know
it's inevitable that somewhere around
here there start to be problems that
people have a situation that nothing
works and everything is too slow and you
panic and this happens I wish you luck
of course I mean what can you do about
it I mean it can be really hard when you
have things that don't work as to work
out why they don't work and how to fix
them I mean I think often the best thing
to do is really to go back to something
simple that you can get working and to
work forward from there again it also
really helps to have really small data
sets I really recommend the strategy of
sort of having a ten item or 20 item
data set and checking that your model
works perfectly over trains to 100%
accuracy on that kind of data set saves
you huge amounts of time and it's sort
of after you've gone something simple
working on a small amount of data that's
the right time to serve then expand
forward again
you should definitely always make sure
that you can completely over fit on your
training data set that sort of and not
quite a proof but as at least the first
good requirement for your model being
implemented properly you you know part
of the trick of being a successful deep
learning researcher is actually managing
to get things done and not wasting a ton
of time and so it definitely always
helps just to be you know plotting as
you go along your training and dev
errors so that you can sort of tell if
things are working or if things aren't
working and you should abandon and start
again with a new experiment that just
things like that save you hours and get
you more done and so then once things
are working this sort of a whole bunch
of things to make it work better
there's regularization with l2 and drop
out there's time to do hyper parameter
search
and you know often doing these things
and make quite a lot of difference to
what your final results are and so it's
good to have time to do those things but
qu you want to get things working first
before you go on to that and sort of
really encourage people to still stop by
in office hours if you've got any
problems and we'll try our best to help
though here within the limitations of
what we can do from just being hit cold
with problems okay yeah so I wanted to
sort of just say some general remarks
about language and theories of language
that in the context that motivate this
tree recursive networks so this is an
art installation at Carnegie Mellon
University and as an NLP person I really
love this art installation so we need
better art installations around the
Stanford School of Engineering so this
is the bag of words art installation
there's the bag with a lot of words in
it and you see down here there are the
stop words the dart and the us that have
fallen out of the bag and a represented
on the ground as the stop words
beautiful artwork right so one of the
interesting things that has been found
about NLP models of language and I think
this is even more true in the deep
learning world than it used to be
previously is boy you can do a lot with
bag of words models right that you can
just often get a lot of power by saying
well let's get our new word vectors
we're gonna average them or max pull
them or something like this and do
nothing more and that gives me a pretty
good sentence representation or document
representation that I could use in a
classifier or something and sometimes
you can do not much more than that and
get even better so people have done
things like deep averaging networks
where you're taking the output of a bag
of words model and sort of feeding it
through a couple more layers and
improving things so that is in complete
distinction to what's been dominant in
linguistic
of looking at language structure that
typically in linguistics the emphasis
has been on identifying kind of huge
amounts of structure of linguistics
utterances through very complex
formalisms I guess this is sort of a bit
of a picture of a Chomsky in minimalism
syntactic tree and the one at the top is
a bit of a picture of had driven phrase
structure grammar theory there was
predominantly developed at Stanford in
the in the 90s but so very complex data
structures and articulator structures
used to describe linguistics and there's
a huge gap between these two things
and you might think that you know surely
there's some good points in the middle
where we have a certain amount of
structure and that's going to help us do
what we want and so in particular that
if we wanted to semantically interpret
language it seems like we don't just
want to have word vectors we want to
have meanings of bigger phrases so
here's the snowboarder at leaping over a
mogul and a person on a snowboard jumps
into the air and what we'd like to be
able to say is that the snowboarder
means basically the same thing as a
person on a snowboard so we want to have
these chunks of language which in
linguistics of be constituents phrases
and say that they have a meaning and
we'd like to be able to compare their
meaning now we've looked at at least one
tool that allows us to have chunks of
language right because we looked at
convolutional neural networks where you
could take three words and make a
representation of the convolutional
neural network but the fundamental
difference is that in human languages
you have these chunks that have meaning
there are different sizes so we'd like
to say the snowboarder is pretty much
semantically equivalent to a person on a
snowboard but the top one is two words
long and the bottom one is five words
long and so if we're going to be able to
do that we somehow want to have these
sort of constituent chunks
and be able to work with and represent
them in neural networks and that's sort
of the central idea of what motivated
some of the sort of tree structured
neural networks are about to show you
there's another related thing that you
might want to think about is you know a
person on a snowboard how do human
beings manage to understand what that
means and then a person on a snowboard
jumps into the air
how does people manage to understand
what that means and it sort of seems
like the only possible answer to this is
what's normally referred to as the
principle of compositionality that
people know the word person they know
the word on they know the words
snowboard therefore they can work out
what on a snowboard means and they can
work out what person on a snowboard
means by knowing the meanings of
components and putting them together
into bigger pieces there's a there's a
famous applied mathematician
statistician at Brown University study
Minh and I guess the way he summarized
this is either the principle of
compositionality is true or God exists
very shiva's where you take that as you
as you want but you know I think what he
meant was well you know you can just
make these infinite number of infinitely
long sentences and human beings
understand them then it just has to be
that people can know about words and
waits to combine meanings and and make
bigger meanings cause you know how else
could it possibly work that people could
understand sentences and so we want to
be able to do that we want to be able to
work out semantic compositions of
smaller elements to work out the
meanings of bigger pieces and that this
obviously isn't only a linguistic thing
compositionality appears in other places
as well right so if you want to
understand how some piece of machinery
works what you kind of want to know is
it has different sub components and if
you can understand how the differ
subcomponents work and how they're
fitted together then you might have some
understanding of how the whole scene
works and compositionality seems to be
worked at work in vision as well so here
is a scene and again it seems like this
scene has parts so there are little
parts that go together right so there
are people that go together into a crowd
of people and there's a roofer and a
second floor and another bit of roof and
the first floor that go together into a
picture of this church and so this is
also kind of a compositional scene in
which pieces go together so it sort of
seems like certainly for language
understanding and then really for a lot
of the other things that we use for
intelligence then we somehow need to be
able to understand bigger things from
knowing about smaller parts yeah so
computational so the most fun I
mentioned this earlier sometime the most
famous linguist is Noam Chomsky at MIT
and you know really computational
linguists a lot of the time haven't been
that friendly to linguistics linguists
and in particular some of Noam Chomsky's
theories of language because really he's
never been sympathetic to the idea of
machine learning or in general just sort
of the empirical ability to learn from
data he's sort of has always been
wanting to refuse that that exists but
if we nevertheless look for a little bit
of insight on that you know this is a
recent paper of Chomsky's with authors
and that they're sort of trying to give
a version of what is unique about human
language and essentially what they zero
in on is that well if you're sort of
looking at you know humans versus other
fairly intelligent creatures they
suggest that the defining difference of
human beings is that they have this
ability to model recursion and so the
this paper argues that the the singular
distinction that allowed language to
develop in human beings
that we could put together smaller parts
to make bigger things in a recursive
process and that that was the sort of
defining new ability not sure not sure I
believe that or not you can decide what
you think but what I think is certainly
the case is if there's just
incontrovertible that the structure of
human language sentences have these
pieces of constituents that then form
together hierarchically or recursively
into bigger pieces as you go up in the
tree and then particularly you get this
recursion where you get a little noun
phrase meat which then appears in a
bigger noun phrase like spaghetti with
meat and you can repeat that several
times giving you a curse of structure
and I have an example of that in blue up
the top so the person standing next to
the man from the company that purchased
the firm that's used to work at that
whole thing is big noun phrase but
inside that there's a noun phrase the
man from the company that purchased the
firm that used to work ad which is
another big noun phrase and well inside
that there are smaller noun phrase like
the company that purchased the firm used
to work at but you know it's still got
inside that noun phrases like the firm
that you used to work at and actually
even that's gotten inside at a smaller
noun phrase which is just the word you
so a individual pronoun is also a noun
phrase so this kind of structuring of
language where you get this sort of
hierarchical structure at the same kind
of things inside them I think that's
just sort of totally totally correct the
the claim then that you know our
language is recursive I mean in a formal
sense it's not quite clear that that's a
it's a clear thing and that's the reason
to say something this recursive it has
to repeat out to infinity
right so as soon as you put any bound on
something and you
say look that's it now I'm afraid you
just gave me with five levels of nesting
that's pretty implausible that someone
is going to say that and so as soon as
you sort of want to make an argument
like okay even if they said that no one
is going to say a noun phrase with ten
levels of nesting and if you put some
hard limit on it like that then in some
sense it's not truly recursive because
it doesn't go out to infinity but you
know regardless what you think about
that that doesn't negate the basic
argument that you get this hierarchical
structuring with the same kinds of
things like noun phrases sentences verb
phrases appearing inside each other in a
way that has no clear bound the extent
that I show you a complex sentence you
can say I can make them an even bigger
more complex sentence by putting it
inside you said to me that and then
saying my sentence right so that's the
sense in which it does appear to be a
recursive generative process even though
practically there are limits to how
complex sentences people say and so
that's the kind of structure that gets
captured in these constituency structure
trees so before the early time when we
talked about parsing and you guys did
some of it I emphasized dependency
parsing but the other kind of parsing
which is actually the kind that the
models I'm going to talk about today I
was using was this idea of what's often
called constituency parsing or linguists
often call at phrase structure grammar
x' or in sort of computer science formal
language theory these are context-free
grammars where we are having these non
terminals like noun phrase and verb
phrase and that's inside anon the noun
phrase that's inside another verb phrase
which is inside more verb phrases
heading up the sentence and so these are
our constituency grammars and when we
occasionally mentioned the pin treebank
tree this was kind of an original pin
treebank tree which is basically for a
structure grammar like this with sort of
various extra annotations
put on the nodes okay so what it's seen
what what you to capture some of these
properties it seems like we'd like to
have a neural model that can make use of
some of this same kind of tree structure
and so what we'd like to do for working
out semantic similarity of constituents
is we want to not only have a word
vector space like we start off with
right at the beginning of the quarter
but we'd like to be able to take bigger
constituents like noun phrases the
country of my birth and the place where
I was born and also give them a meaning
and so it seems like what we'd like to
do is have a method of computing the
meaning of any phrase in a compositional
manner such that the end result is also
that these phrases could be stuck inside
our vector space models so we're still
going to stick with a vector space
semantics of phrases and we want to
compute the meanings of phrases and so
then the question is how could we go
about doing that and we'll answer number
one is we kind of use the principle of
compositionality since we're sure it's
right and so well what the principle of
compositionality essentially says if you
want to work out the meaning well here
it says of a sentence but the meaning of
any phrase any constituent is you're
going to build it by knowing the
meanings of its words and then having
rules that combine these meanings so
starting off with the country of my
birth I should be able to calculate a
meaning of my birth and meaning of the
country a meaning of of the my birth and
then a meaning of the country of my
birth so we'd have meaning composition
rules which will let us calculate
meanings upwards for larger constituents
or sentences so that seems kind of the
right thing to do and so then the
question is well can we then build a
model of how to do that
well here's sort of a straightforward
way of doing this okay so we
we have word vectors for the words that
we've calculated and what we'd like to
do is work out then a meaning
representation of this sentence and at
this point we sort of have two things to
do we have parsing to do where here
what's the right structure of the
sentence and then we have meaning
computation to do of working out what is
the meaning representation of this
sentence so for parsing we'd sort of be
building sort of noun phrase
prepositional phrase verb phrase
sentence kind of units to get the cat
sat on the mat and then we'll what we if
we had that we could then run some kind
of meaning computation program and give
us sort of a vector space meaning of
these sentences so that's kind of what
we want is to do both of those and in a
little bit I'll show you an example of
the kind of one way that you go about
approaching that but before I do that
just sort of stepping back for a moment
as to what's different here write that
here we had our recurrent neural network
which in some sense has been our
workhorse tool in this class up to now
and it gives you it gives you a
representation of the meaning of the
country of my birth sort of you could
either say that's the meaning of the
country of my birth or we talked about
other tricks like doing max pooling
across all of these or you could have a
separate node out here which sort of
does attention over the ease so it does
give you a sort of representation of the
meaning of this of any subsequence of
words as well but they sort of different
right that this what the top the tree
recursive neural network it requires a
sentence or any kind of phrase to have a
tree structure so we know what its
component parts are but then we're
working out meaning representations for
the phrase that are sensitive to what
its syntactic structure is that how the
words go together to build phrases
whereas for there were current neural
network we're just in an oblivious way
running a sequence model along and
saying compute things and in the obvious
it doesn't in any obvious way give a
meaning representation of my birth or my
birth contained inside it we sort of
only have a meaning representation for
the whole sequence whereas if we're
doing things this way we do have meaning
representations for the different
meaningful parts of the sentence okay
that makes sense of what we're trying to
do okay so how could we do it go about
doing that well the idea of how we could
go about doing that is if we work
bottom-up at the very bottom we have
word vectors and so we want to
recursively compute the meaning of
bigger constituents so if we wanted to
compute the meaning of on the mat what
we can do is say well we have already
have a meaning representation of on and
mat so if we could feed those into a
neural network because that's one tool
we could maybe get out of it two things
we could get out of it a goodness score
so this is what we're going to use for
parsing we're going to say do you
believe do you believe you can put
together on and the mat to form a good
constituent that's part of a parse tree
and this will be a big positive number
if the answer is true and negative if
that's not true and then we have a
meaning composition device which says
okay if you put together these two
things what would be the meaning
representation of what we put together
and so this is the first model that we
explored which was doing this in a
pretty simple way right so here was our
meaning composition device that we
concatenated the two vectors of the
constituents we multiply them by matrix
atoms I'm a biased as usual put it
through at NH this work is old enough
it's sort of before things like values
became pop
pila but maybe it's better to have at an
age anyway but more like recurrent
neural network and so this was our
meaning composition that gave the
meaning of the parent and then to the
side what the score if it was as to
whether this was a good phrase we were
taking that parent vector representation
and multiplying it by another vector and
that was giving us out a number if you
think about it a bit while we're doing
this you might think that this isn't
quite a perfect model of meaning
composition and later on in the class
I'll talk about some more complex models
that we then started to explore that
this is sort of enough to get us going
and this gave us a way of building a
recursive neural network parser which
both found parsers and worked out a
meaning representation for them and so
the way we did this was in the simplest
possible way really which was to have a
greedy parser
so if we start off with the cat sat on
the mat what we could do is say well
maybe you should join that and cat
together let's try that run it through
our neural network it'll get a score and
a meaning representation and while we
could try doing that for cat and Sat we
could try doing it for satin on we could
try doing it for Anand our we could try
doing it for that and mat and then at
this point we'd say okay well the the
best phrase that we can make combining
these word vectors is the one for that
cat so let's just commit to that one and
it has this semantic representation and
at this point we can essentially repeat
now all the work we did over there we
can just reuse because nothing has
changed but we can also consider now
joining the cat as a constituent with
Sat and get a score for that and so at
this point we decide okay the mat is the
best constituent to build commit to that
calculate a meaning representation for
on the mat that looks good commit to
that and kind of keep on chugging up and
so we've got a mechanism for sort of
choosing a pars of the sentence in a in
a
really manner but you know when we
looked at the dependency parsing we're
also doing that greedily right and
coming up with a meaning representation
okay so that was our first model of
having a tree recursive neural network
and using it for parsing there are a few
more details here some of which probably
aren't super important at this point
right so we could score a tree by
summing the scores at each node for
working out for the optimization we were
working out we're using this kind of Max
margin loss that we've looked at in
other places the simplest way to do
things is completely greedily you just
find the best local decision each point
and make that structure and keep on
going but if you want to do things a bit
better and we explore this you could say
we could do beam search we could explore
out several good ways emerging and then
the side later higher up the tree as to
which was the best way to merge we
haven't talked about it in this class
but just to mention something in case
people have seen it is traditional
constituency parsing where you have
symbols here like MP or VP there exist
efficient dynamic programming algorithms
where you can find the optimal pars of a
sentence in polynomial time
so in cubic time so if you have a
regular context-free grammar and well so
a regular probabilistic context-free
grammar and you want to know what is the
best part of the sentence according to
the probabilistic context-free grammar
you can write a cubic time dynamic
programming algorithm and you can find
it that's good and in the old days of
cs2 24in before neural networks we used
to have everyone do that the the most
the most brain breaking assignment of
the old cs2 24n was writing this dynamic
program to do context-free grammar
parsing of a sentence the slightly sad
fact
is once you go to these kind of neural
network representations you can't write
clever dynamic programming algorithms
anymore because clever dynamic
programming algorithms only work when
you have symbols from a reasonably small
set for your non terminals because if
that's the case you can you kind of have
collisions right you have lots of ways
of parsing stuff lower down
which come up turn out to be different
ways to make a noun phrase or different
ways to make a prepositional phrase and
therefore you can save work with dynamic
programming if you've got a model like
this since everything that you build is
going through layers of neural network
and you've got a meaning representation
of some high dimensional vector things
are never going to collide and so you
can never save work by doing dynamic
programming and so you're either doing
exponential work to explore out
everything or else you're using some
kind of beam to explore a bunch of
likely stuff yeah we actually also
applied this to vision at the same time
so it wasn't just so completely a vague
motivation of visual scenes have parts
that we actually started exploring that
well you could take these pieces of
scenes and then work out representations
for scenes using a similar form of
compositionality and so in particular
there was sort of this data set that was
being used for multi-class segmentation
envision where you start off with very
small patches and then you want to
combine them out into parts of a scene
of sort of recognizing which part of the
picture was the building the sky the
road various other classes and we were
actually at the time able to do this
really rather well using one of these
tree recursive structured neural
networks better than preceding work and
vision had done in the late 2000s decade
okay so how can how can we build neural
networks that do this kind of stuff
and so when when we started off
exploring this tree structured neural
networks we thought that this was a cool
original idea and no one had worked on
tree structured neural networks
successfully before but it turned out we
were wrong that there are a couple of
Germans in the mid-1990s who actually
started looking at tree structured
neural networks and had worked out the
math of them so corresponding to the
back propagation through time algorithm
that ABI talked about when we were doing
recurrent neural networks they worked
out the tree structured case which they
called back propagation through
structure there are several slides on
this in these slides but I think I'm
gonna sort of skip them if anyone wants
to look at them there on the web and you
can look at them I mean there isn't
actually anything that's new so if you
remember with with bad scarring or
something those early lectures of this
class of working out the derivatives of
neural networks and how it worked with
recurrent neural networks it's sort of
the same right you gave this recurrent
matrix had different levels of tree
structure you're summing the derivatives
of everywhere it turns up the only
difference is sort of because we now
have tree structure you're sort of
splitting things downwards so yeah so
for drop we find the computer forwards
and then when we're doing back crop when
we've have the backward propagation we
have the error signal coming from above
we then combine it with the calculations
that this node and then we're sort of
sending it back in a tree structure down
to each of the branches underneath us so
that was our first version of things you
know we got some decent result we got
this good vision results and I showed
you and it sort of seemed to do some
good for language both for parsing and
doing we had some results I haven't
actually included here of sort of doing
paraphrase judgment between sentences
and and model things fail
well but once we started thinking about
it more it seemed like that very simple
neural net function couldn't possibly
compute the kind of meanings that we
wanted to compute for sentence meanings
and so we then sort of said about trying
to come up with some more complex ways
of working out kind of meaning
composition functions and modes that
could then be used to build a better
neural network and sort of sudden some
of the essence of that is on this slide
that you know for the first version we
just didn't have enough complexity of
neural network frankly right so when we
had two constituents we concatenated
them and multiply that by a weight
weight matrix and that was sort of
essentially all we had and as I hope
you've gone more of a sense of in this
class if you just concatenate and
multiply by weight matrix you're not
actually modeling the interaction
between these two vectors right because
you can think of this weight matrix is
just sort of being divided in two and
half of it multiplies that this vector
and half of it multiplies this vector so
the meanings of these two things don't
act on each other and so somehow you
have to make your neural network more
complex than that but the other way in
which this seemed too simple is in the
first model we had just one weight
matrix which we use for everything and
at least if you're a linguist and you're
thinking about the structure of language
you might start thinking of well wait a
minute sometimes you're going to be
putting together a verb and an object
noun phrase hit the ball sometimes
you're going to be putting together an
article and a noun our ball sometimes
you're going to be doing adjective or
modification blue ball these things are
very different in their semantics can it
really be the case that you can just
have one weight matrix that is this
universal composition function for
putting together meaning of phrases
could that possibly work and you sort of
might suspect it doesn't work
and so I'm going to go on and show some
of those different things but really
before I show the different things I'm
going to show one more version that sort
of related to the first thing which
actually gave a pretty successful and
good parser or edit for doing context
free style constituency parsing and so
this was another way of getting away
from the parsing being completely greedy
which was to actually split apart the
two parts of gee we have to come up with
a tree structure for our sentence from
let's compute the meaning of the
sentence and so the thinking was well in
terms of deciding what's a good tree
structure for a sentence that's actually
something you can do pretty well with a
symbolic grammar that the problems with
symbolic grammars aren't that they can't
put tree structures over sentences the
problems you have with those grammars is
that they can't compute meaning
representation and they're not very good
at choosing between alternative tree
structures but we could divide up the
two parts so what we could do is say
well let's just use a regular
probabilistic context-free grammar to
generate possible tree structures for
sentences we can generate a key best
list and say what are the 50 best
context-free grammar structures for this
sentence and that's something we can do
very efficiently with dynamic
programming algorithms and then we can
work out a neural net that will work out
the meaning representation of the
sentence and so that led to this what's
called syntactically untied recursive
neural network so essentially what this
is saying is that we had for each node
in the sentence it's got a category of a
symbolic context-free grammar so there
category
and B and C so when we put things
together we'll be able to say okay we've
got a rule that says X goes to BC so
that licenses this node here so that
part of the parsing is symbolic then
then we want to work out the meaning of
this phrase and well the second problem
I talked about was surely just having
one way of doing composition is
expecting a lot too much to be able to
have sort of urban object versus
adjective and noun composed the same way
so we had this idea of well since we've
now know about the syntactic categories
of the children that we maybe know that
this is an adjective and this is a noun
what we could do is have different
weight matrices for composition
depending on what the categories are so
rather than where before there was just
this one universal weight matrix which
was meant to do all meaning composition
here we can have this is the weight
matrix for combining together the
meanings of an adjective and a noun and
it will compute the meaning of this
constituent but then we'll have a
different weight matrix for combining
together the meanings of a determiner
and a noun phrase or something like that
okay yeah so I sort of already said this
one I guess we wanted to be able to do
things quickly and so our solution to be
able to do that is we sort of used a
probabilistic context-free grammar to
find likely parsers and then only worked
out our meaning for ones that were quite
probable and so we call this result a
compositional vector grammar which was a
combination of a pcfg and a tree
recursive neural network and yes so
essentially at the time this actually
gave a pretty good constituent
see Pazza so there are sort of lots of
results here the top ones are kind of
our classic older Stanford parser which
is a pcfg are the kind of parsers that
people have built this is our
compositional vector grammar
at the time of this being done in 2013
it wasn't the very best paths are
available there'd been some better work
by Eugene charniak at Brown but we
actually had a pretty good parser
coming out of that system but what was
perhaps a bit more interesting was we we
didn't only have a part of those meant
to give the right parse trees we're also
computing meaning representations of
nodes and as a kind of a consequence of
that you could look at not only meaning
representations of nodes you could learn
about the weight matrices that these
models were learning when they combine
together meanings so remember we have
these sort of category specific W
matrices that were going together with
the children to work out the meaning so
these are a little bit hard to interpret
but the deal is when weilert these
matrices we initialize them as a pair of
diagonal matrices so these are so two by
one rectangular matrices because there
are two children so half of it is
multiplying the left child the other
half is multiplying the right child and
we initialize them as sort of like a
complete two identity matrices next to
each other which would give us the sort
of default semantics of just averaging
until something different was learnt in
the in the in the weight vectors and to
the extent that sort of nothing
interesting has been learnt by the model
you'll get yellow along the diagonal and
this sort of sky-blue in the rest of the
field and the extent that it's learnt
something interesting to take out of the
semantics of a child you'll then start
to see reds and oranges on the diagonal
on dark blues and greens and stuff in
the rest of the field so what you find
is that if you train this model it's
learn
about which children of a phrase are
actually the important ones so these
ones are saying that if you're combining
together a noun phrase and the
coordination so something like the cat
and that most of the semantics is to be
found in the cat and not much of the
semantics is going to be found in and
whereas if you're combining together a
possessive pronoun something like her or
hears with a noun phrase insider like
her tabby cat or something like that and
most of the meaning is to be found
inside the tabby cat constituent so it's
actually learning where the important
semantics of sentences is and there are
lots of examples of that yeah this one
sort of so this one shows a variety of
modification structures where adjectives
or adverbs modify either a noun phrase
or an adjective phrase or just a single
adjective ISM multiplying a noun phrase
and the thing that you seem to notice is
that there are particular dimensions
which are kind of capturing sort of
modification meaning so dimension six
and dimension eleven is sort of showing
up in these different combinations here
sort of capturing meaning component so
that was kind of neat and so this
slightly more complex model actually
worked pretty well at capturing a
meaning of phrases and sentences so in
this test here we were giving it at the
system a test sentence and saying well
what are the other what are sentences
that are most similar in meaning nearest
to paraphrases in our corpus for this
sentence so far all the figures are
adjusted for seasonal variations the two
most similar other sentences in the
corpus were all the numbers are adjusted
for seasonal vet fluctuation that's a
pretty easy one or all the figures are
adjusted to remove usual seasonal
patterns so that seems to be working
pretty well night
you know one comment on the offer haskó
declined to say what country placed the
order the semantics they're a bit more
different but it seems like it is
capturing something similar
coastal wouldn't disclose the terms
that's kind of a really interesting one
because that one is actually very
similar in meaning but it's expressed in
a very different way in terms of the
words and the syntactic structure that
are used
okay so that was progress because now we
could have different matrices for
different constituent types but there's
still some reason to think that we
didn't have enough power and that was we
are still at heart using this very
simple compositional structure we were
just concatenated to children's vectors
and multiplying it by a matrix so that
means the two words didn't interact with
each other in terms of their meaning but
it seems like we want to have them
interact in their meaning right so in
particular if you if you think about
human languages and the kind of things
that people look at at linguistic
semantics you get words that appear to
be kind of modifiers or operators so the
word very sort of doesn't mean much by
itself I mean it means something like
strengthening or more so or something
like that but you know it doesn't really
have a meaning right it doesn't have any
D notation you can't show me very things
right you can show me chairs and pins
and children but you can't show me very
things that the meaning of very seems to
be that something comes after it good
and this has a sort of an operator
meaning of increase on the scale this
thing and it can increase on the scale
in either direction you can have very
good or very bad so if we want to
capture that kind of semantics it seems
like we can't capture that kind of
semantics by just can-can
needing two vectors and multiplying them
by a matrix it seems like what we really
want to say is very is going to grab
hold of the meaning of good and modify
it in some ways to produce a new meaning
for very good and indeed that's the kind
of approach that's typically been done
in linguistic semantics so in linguistic
theories of semantics you'd normally say
okay good has a meaning very as a
function that takes in the meaning of
good and returns a meaning very good and
so we wanted to have a way of putting
that into a neural network and so to try
and come up with a new composition
function as to how to do that and there
are various ways that you could think
about doing that and other people have
had a couple of different attempts but
essentially what was in our head is well
we have word vectors and if we want to
say that 'very takes the meaning of good
and returns a new meaning the kind of
obvious thing to do is to say very has a
matrix attached to it because then we
can use the the very matrix and multiply
it by the good vector and we get a new
vector coming out and so then well the
problem is which in which words have
vectors and which words have matrices
and that's kind of hard to know the
answer to I mean in particular words
that act as operators can often
themselves be modified and so that you
know good can also good also is a
operator right so that from a sort of a
person you can have a good person that's
sort of also an operator and very is
modifying that good so the idea we came
up with is let's not try and
predetermine all of this why don't we
say that every word and
phrase has connected to it both a matrix
and the vector so here's our very good
movie
so for each word we have a vector
meaning and it has a matrix meaning and
then as we start to build up phrases
like very good they're also going to
have a vector meaning and a matrix
meaning and so what we proposed was so
first of all we we would like to be able
to calculate the vector meanings so to
work out the vector meaning of a phrase
like very good each word has a matrix
meaning and so we're going to combine
their opposing matrix and vector
meanings so we're going to take the
matrix meaning of good and multiply it
by the vector meaning of 'very and we're
going to take the matrix meaning of
'very and multiply it by the vector
meaning of good and so we're going to
have both of those two things and then
we're going to have a neural network
layer like before that combine those
together and so that sort of in the red
box then those two things were
concatenated and put through the kind of
neural network layer we had before to
give us a final vector meaning for this
for the phrase and then we also needed a
matrix meaning for the phrase and so for
the matrix meaning for the fray is we
did this kind of simple model which
maybe actually wasn't very good which
was to say let's just concatenate the
two matrices of the the constituents
multiply them by another matrix and
that's then going to give us a matrix
version of the parent node and so this
was gave us our new more company more
powerful composition procedure this did
seem like it could do some kind of good
things that captured a sort of operator
semantics where one word modified the
meaning of another word so here's a kind
of a neat
that we were able to do with this that
we are wanting to be able to work out
the semantics of an operator modifying
another word so unbelievably annoying
unbelievably awesome unbelievably sad
not annoying not awesome not sad
and so this was contrasting our old
model versus the new model and this
scale is a scale of positive to negative
so this is completely negative to
completely positive right and so the
kind of contrasts you get that for not
annoying that the simple model thought
that this is pretty negative whereas the
new model thinks this is pretty neutral
and meaning and that seems to be
reasonably correct for not sad that
means it's a little bit positive and
both models we're trying to kept capture
that then you know the results here a
little bit ambivalent but it sort of
seems that they sort of go a little bit
in the direction of what we want yes
this ground truth was we actually asked
a whole bunch of human beings to say
race the meaning of not sad on this
scale of 1 to 10 maybe this wasn't a
very good clear task because as you can
see it bounced around a lot
uh-huh what kind of ratings we were
getting for things but yeah that was
actually going to gain human judgments
we also then used this model to say well
could we do semantic classification
tasks so if we wanted to understand
relations between different noun phrases
so this was a data set where there were
relations marked between two noun
phrases my apartment has a
pretty large kitchen that was seen as an
example of a component whole a a part of
relationship between the two noun
phrases and there were other
relationships between different kinds of
noun phrases so for us the movie showed
wars that that was then a message topic
so there's some communication medium
that contains some topic relationship
and so we were using this kind of neural
network to sort of build our meaning
representations and then putting them
through another neural network layer as
a classifier to see how well we did and
so we got some sort of fairly good
results on that so this was a data set
that people had worked on with
traditional NLP systems of different
kinds of machine learning methods but in
some sense you know what we're
interested in was we seem to be making
progress in having a better semantic
composition system that our old
recursive neural network was getting
about 75% and then our new one was
getting about 79% which we could sort of
push up further by putting more features
into our system so that was progress but
we didn't stop there
and we kept on trying to come up with
better ways of doing things and so even
though things worked fairly well here it
sort of seemed like this way of doing
matrices wasn't necessarily very good it
sort of had two problems one problem was
it introduced a humongous number of
parameters because you know for just
about everything that we've done
otherwise words have had a vector and
well maybe sometimes we use quite high
dimensional vectors like a thousand and
twenty four but you know that's a
relatively modest number of parameters
whereas once we introduced this matrix
here we've got that number of squared
additional parameters for every word and
essentially because of that number of
parameters to be able to compute this
model at all we were making the vet
the size small so what we're actually
using was of these were just 25
dimensional vectors so that the 25
squared 625 still saved sort of decently
within the range in which we could
compute so that was the first problem
the second problem is we didn't really
have very good ways I'm sort of building
up the matrix meaning of bigger phrases
I mean you know this sort of seems
something simple we could do but it
didn't you know feel a very good way of
getting a matrix meaning of a phrase so
he sort of wanted to come up with some
other way of doing things
that could fix both of those problems
and then that led in to work on
recursive neural tenser networks and
there's a kind of a nice idea here of
these neural tensors which is an idea
that's actually being used in other
places including work on sort of putting
vector embeddings of knowledge graphs
and so on which is a kind of a bit of a
nice idea so I wanted to sort of show a
bit of how this model works and but just
to say first a place where we applied
this model was on the problem of
sentiment analysis now I think the term
sentiment analysis has come up a few
times as something you can do and
actually Richard and mention the last
lecture but I think we've never really
talked for five minutes in this class on
sentiment analysis so I'll give you this
as an example of that sentiment analysis
has actually been a really common and
important application in natural
language processing you're looking at a
piece of text and you're sort of saying
is it positive or negative and that's
just something that's very useful for
lots of commercial applications of
looking at product reviews or doing
brand awareness and things like that of
sort of looking at sentiment connected
to things and to some extent doing
sentiment analysis is easy right that
you can kind of say well look at a piece
of text if you see words like loved
great impressed
and it's positive it's a positive review
and if it's saying bad and awful then
it's a negative review and to some
extent that's the baseline of sentiment
analysis that you can use just either
selected word features or all words in a
bag of words and if you do that you
don't actually do that badly in
sentiment analysis if you have longer
documents just looking at bags of words
can give you 90% in sentiment analysis
but on the other hand things often do
get trickier right so this is from
Rotten Tomatoes with this cast and this
subject matter the movie should have
been funnier and more entertaining and
if you sort of pretend you're a bag of
words model the only words in this that
are sort of clearly sentiment Laden
words entertaining and funnier and both
of those are pretty positive words but
it's fairly obvious that this actually
isn't meant to be a bad review of the
movie and so well how are we meant to
know that well it sort of seems again
like what we have to do as meaning
composition we have to get sort of
phrases like should have been funnier
and then realized that that's actually a
negative meaning for a phrase and so we
wanted to explore how we could look at
those sort of meanings for phrases and
explore building up those meanings as
doing meaning composition over trees um
so the first thing we did was we built a
tree Bank of sentiment trees where we
got people to rate sentiment and so this
led to the Stanford sentiment tree Bank
which is still a data set you often see
used in various of evaluations with a
whole bunch of data sets indeed that
showed up in Decorah NLP last week so
what we were doing this was taking
sentences which were Rotten Tomatoes
sentences from movies we were parsing
them to give tree structure and then we
were asking Mechanical Turk URLs to rate
the
different free the different words and
phrases on a sentiment scale of very
positive to very negative so lots of
stuff is white because it's just not
sentiment Laden right there's words that
are there and there's phrases like the
movie and the movie was which don't
really have any sentiment but then you
have pieces of sort of very positive
pieces of tree and negative pieces of
tree that are then shown in the blue and
the red and so typically in sentiment
datasets people have only labeled the
entire sentence to say this is a
positive sentence or a very positive
sentence this is a negative sentence or
a very negative sentence crucially what
we were doing differently here is every
phrase in the sentence according to our
tree structure was being given a label
for its positivity or negativity and
perhaps not surprisingly just the fact
that you have a lot more annotations
like that just improves the behavior of
classifiers because you kind of can do
better
attribution of which words in a sentence
a positive or negative so these were
were results of sort of preceding models
so the green is a naive Bayes model
except it not only uses individual words
but it uses pairs of words it turns out
if you're building at a traditional
classifier and you want to do sentiment
analysis as opposed to something like
topic classification you get a lot
better results if you also use word pair
features and that's because it does a
baby bit of composition for you you
don't only have features for not an
interesting but you can have a feature
for not interesting and that lets you
model a certain amount of stuff and then
these are our older generations of
neural networks our original tree
structured neural network and our matrix
vector one and so simply having for
these so fixed models simply having the
richer supervision that comes from our
new tree Bank it sort of moved up the
performance of every model so even
for just the naivebayes models
performances going up about 4% because
of the fact that it now knows more about
which particular words are positive or
negative in the sentences but still none
of these performances are really great
so we still thought that well can we
build better models of how to do this in
particular if you look at sentences with
sort of various kinds of negation you
know things like should have been
funnier these models in general still
couldn't capture the right meanings for
them and so that led into our fourth
model of how to do this which is this
idea of recursive neural tenser networks
and so what we wanted to be able to do
is go back to just having meanings of
words be vectors but nevertheless
despite that to be able to have a
meaning for a phrase where the two
vectors acted on each other and well you
know this kind of this is the picture of
what we did when we were doing attention
in a bilinear way right we had vectors
for two words we stuck a matrix in
between and we use that and gave an
attention and got an attention score out
so that let these two vectors interact
with each other but it only produced one
number as the output but there's a way
to fix that which is to say well rather
than having matrix here what we could
stick here is a three dimensional cube
which physicists and deep learning
people caught now call a tensor right so
a tensor is just higher
multi-dimensional array in computer
science terms so if we sort of made that
a tensor you know it's like we have sort
of multiple layers and matrix here and
so the end result of that is we get one
number here and one number here
so in total we get out of size two
vector which is all we need and my baby
example where we baby examples where we
only have these two component vectors
for words but in general we have a
tensor with the extra mention dimension
of the size of our word vector and so
therefore we'll get a word vector at
work we'll get a phrase vector out from
the composition that's the same size of
the input vectors and will allow them to
interact with each other in working out
the meaning of the entire thing okay
right at that point we use the resulting
vectors so we had our new tensor network
we actually combined it together with
this sort of previous kind of layer we
used to have our first R and then maybe
you didn't need to do this but we just
decided we're betting as well put things
through a non-linearity and that was
then giving us our new representation of
Fraser's we built that up the tree and
then at the end we could classify the
meaning of any phrase in the same kind
of way with softmax regression and we
could train these weights with gradient
descent to predict sentiment and so this
actually worked pretty nicely I'm in
particular it didn't show really work
any better with just the sentence labels
but if we train the model with our tree
bank we could then get a kind of
whatever that is about another couple of
percent and performance and so that
seemed good and so in particular it
seemed to do a much better job of
actually understanding meaning
composition so here's the kind of
sentence where you have there a slow and
repetitive parts but it has just enough
spice to keep it interesting and the
models seem you know pretty good at
understanding ok this part of the
sentence is negative this part of the
sentence is positive and actually when
you stick the two halves together the
end result is the sentence there's
positive and meaning
but focusing in a little bit more what
seems like it's especially good was for
the first time this actually did seem
like it could do a better job of working
out sort of what happens when you do
things like negation so here we have
it's just incredibly dull and it's
definitely not dull so if it's
definitely not dull that actually means
it's good right can we work out that the
meaning of it's definitely not dull and
so these this is sort of showing a sort
of what happens when you have a negative
and negative sentence that's further
negated so if you go from so if you sort
of do and the in X and the Gatien of a
negative things should become moderately
positive right so that if you have dull
is negative and if you say not dull it
doesn't mean it's fantastic but it means
it's moderately positive and so for
either a kind of naive Bayes model or
our preceding models they weren't
capable of capturing that of sort of
going from dull to not dull your your
meaning computation did not come out any
more positive whereas this sort of neuro
tenser network was capturing the fact
that not dull meant it was reasonably
good so that was progress yeah so I
think that's as much as I'll show you
really now about applying these tree
structured neural networks to natural
language you know I think the summary I
sort of said at the beginning is that I
think you know they're kind of
interesting ideas and linguistic
connections here I mean for various
reasons
these ideas haven't been pursued a ton
in recent years of natural language
processing you know one is in all
honesty people have found that
once you have high dimensional vectors
in things like the kind of sequence
models that we've looked at whether it's
meaning things like the sort of lsdm
models or any of the more recent
contextual language models those work
incredibly well and it's not it's not
clear that over all these models work
better the second reason is sort of a
computational reason which is GPUs work
great when you're doing uniform
computation and the beauty of having
something like a sequence model is that
there's there's just one determinate
computation you're doing along the
sequence or in the convolutional neural
network there's one determinate
computation you're doing up through your
convolutional layers and therefore
things can be represented and computed
efficiently on a GPU the huge problem
with these kind of models was what
computations you were going to do
depended on which structure you're
assigning to the sentence and every
sentence was going to have a different
structure and so therefore there was no
way to batch the computations over a
group of sentences and have the same
computations being done for different
sentences which sort of undermined the
ability to sort of efficiently build
these models in the large the thing I
thought I'd just sort of say a moment
about at the end the funny thing is that
although these haven't been used much
for language in the last few years that
they've actually had some use and found
different applications in different
places which is just sort of seen kind
of cute so this is actually an
application from physics and I think I'm
going to just have to read this since I
have no idea what half the words mean
but what it says is by far the most
common structures seen in collisions at
the Large Hadron Collider a collimated
sprays of energetic hydrants referred to
as Jets these Jets are produced from the
fragmentation and hadron ization of
quarks and gluons as described by
quantum chromo
dynamics anyone knows what that means I
hope you're following along here one
compelling physics challenge is to
search for highly boosted standard model
particles decaying hydraulically
unfortunately there's a large background
from jets produced by more mundane QCD
that's quantum chromodynamics that
processes in this work we propose
instead a solution for jet
classification based on an analogy
between quantum chromodynamics and
natural languages as inspired by several
works from natural language processing
much like a sentence is composed of
words for syntactic structure organized
as the past tree and Jettas are also
composed of four momenta following a
structure dictated by key CD and
organized by the clustering history of a
sequential combination jet algorithm so
anyway um yeah with these jets you see
they've got a tree structure over them
and they're using a tree recursive
neural network to model it well that's a
little bit far afield but to show you
just one more example that another place
where these models have actually been
quite useful is for doing things in
programming languages and I think in
part this is because the application is
easier in programming languages so
unlike a natural language where we have
this uncertainty as to what is the
correct parse tree because there's a lot
of ambiguity in natural language in
programming languages the parse trees
are actually pretty determinate so a
group of people at Berkeley dorm song
and her students have worked on doing
programming language translation by
building tree recursive neural network
encoder decoders so that you're building
up a tree structured neural network
representation of a program in one
language this is a CoffeeScript program
and then you're wanting to build a tree
a tree model which is then translating
that to a program in a different
language
and they've been able to do that and get
good results I was too lazy to retype
this table so this is probably a bit bit
hard to read but what's contrasting is
for a number of programs this is a sort
of CoffeeScript to JavaScript
translation they're comparing using tree
to tree models and then using sequence
to sequence models and then they try
both other combinations sequence to tree
and tree to sequence and what they find
is you can get the best results with the
tree to tree neural network models and
in particular these tree to tree models
are augmented with attention so they
have attention like we talked about the
sequence to sequence models where you're
then being able to do attention back to
nodes in the tree structure which is a
pretty natural way of doing translation
and indeed what these results show is if
you don't have I'll sorry these results
show is if you don't have the attention
operation it doesn't work at all it's
too difficult to get things so done if
you've just sort of trying to create a
single tree representation then say
generate that the translation from that
but if you can do it with this sort of
putting attention into the different
nodes that's great you might if you know
about what CoffeeScript is you might
feel like wait that's cheating slightly
because copy script is a bit too similar
to JavaScript but they've also done it
in other languages so this is going
between Java and c-sharp and this is a
sort of a handwritten Java to c-sharp
converter that you can download from
github if you want but it doesn't
actually work that well and they're able
to show that they're able to build a far
better Java to c-sharp translator doing
that so that's actually kind of cool and
it's good to know the tree structure
recursive neural networks are good for
some things so I'm pleased oh I see work
like this okay I'm just about done but I
thought before finishing I just
mentioned one of
thing which is sort of nothing to do
with natural language processing
precisely but it's about AI but I wanted
to sort of put in a little bit of
advertisement that something that a
number of us have been working on very
hard for the last year or so is
developing a new Stanford Institute for
human centered artificial intelligence
and actually the launch of this
Institute is going to be on Monday of
exam week just when you're maximally
concentrating oh and the things such as
this but our hope is that we can have a
lot of new activity around artificial
intelligence taking a much broader
perspective to artificial intelligence
which is centrally viewing it from the
viewpoint of humans and working out
exploring a large broader range of
issues that embrace a lot of the
interests of the rest of the university
where there's the social sciences and
humanities are also various in
professional schools like the law school
and the business school so to just
quickly say a minute about that that the
the so motivating idea is that sort of
for most of my life sort of AI seem like
a kind of a fun intellectual quest as to
whether you could write bits of software
that did anything halfway intelligent
but that's clearly not what's going to
be what's happening for the next 25
years that we're now at this point in
which artificial intelligence systems
are being unleashed on society
and well hopefully they do some good
things but as we've increasingly been
seeing there are lots of also lots of
opportunities for them to do bad things
and even if we're not imagining
Terminator scenarios there are just lots
of places where people are using machine
learning and AI algorithms for making
decisions some of the worst ones or
things like sentencing guidelines and
courts where you have very biased
algorithms making bad decisions and
people are only starting to become a lot
more aware of the issues and so
effectively we're wanting to have this
Institutes of embracing a lot of the
work of social scientists ethicists and
other people
to actually explore how to have an AI
that's really improving human lives
rather than having the opposite effect
and so the three themes that we're
mainly emphasizing for this Institute is
the first one in the top left is
developing AI technologies but we're
particularly interested in making
linkages back to human intelligence so
cognitive science and neuroscience that
when a lot of the early formative work
in AI was done including all of the
early work in neural networks like the
development of backpropagation it was
actually largely done in the context of
cognitive science right and that was a
sort of a linkage that tended to get
lost in the 90s and 2000's statistical
machine learning emphasis and I think
it'd be good to renew that the top right
there's paying much more attention to
the human and societal impact of AI and
so this is looking at legal issues
economic issues labor forces ethics
great power politics whatever you are
but then down the bottom is something
where it seems like this just kind of
enormous opportunities to do more which
is how can we build technology that
actually augments human lives like to
some extent hero tech we've got
technology with AI augmenting human
lives so all of your cell phones have
speech recognition in them now so you
know that's AI that can augment your
human lives but there's a sense of which
not very much of artificial intelligence
has actually been put into the service
of augmenting human lives like most of
what a cell phone has on it is still
sort of clever and cute stuff done by
HCI people and designers which is very
nice a lot of the time when you're using
your map program or something but we
don't really have much AI inside these
devices helping to make people's lives
better and so we're hoping not only for
individuals but applications like health
care to be doing much more sort of
putting artificial intelligence into
human centered applications
anyway that's my brief advertisement I'm
look out for this while you're not
studying for your exams and I think
there'll be sort of lots of
opportunities for students and others to
be getting more involved in this in the
coming months okay thank you very much
and I will see you later
[Applause]